-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers,
and this is "Late Night."
How's everybody doing tonight?
That's great to hear.
Let's get to the news.
President Biden spoke yesterday
from the East Room
of the White House and said
the situation in Afghanistan
was "rapidly evolving."
No kidding.
Did you see what the Taliban did
in a weekend?
Part of me's like,
"Put them in charge
of the infrastructure bill."
During his address yesterday
about the situation
in Afghanistan,
President Biden attributed
the Taliban's rapid takeover
of the country
to a deal negotiated by
former President Trump
and the incompetence
of the Afghan military,
but added
"the buck stops with me."
Of course, before that,
the buck had quite a journey.
"Really, it all begins when
George Bernard Reynolds
discovered oil in Persia
in 1908.
Now, stay with me, folks."
Former President George W. Bush
released a statement yesterday
about the situation
in Afghanistan,
which is more than he did
in office.
That's right.
George W. Bush
released a statement yesterday
about the situation
in Afghanistan,
and said he will remain
"steadfastly optimistic,"
which, let's face it,
was always his thing.
CNN anchor Chris Cuomo
last night returned
from a week-long
regularly schedule vacation.
Right. Regularly scheduled.
Remember when COVID couldn't
even get this guy off TV,
but his brother resigns
and all of a sudden he's like,
"Nobody likes a workaholic.
Bye!"
[ Laughter ]
New York City's vaccine
requirement for indoor venues
like bars, restaurants, museums,
and movie theaters
went into effect today,
so you can feel perfectly safe
and then leave those places
and get on the subway.
Former NFL quarterback
Jay Cutler was fired last week
from an Uber Eats commercial
because of his anti-mask stance,
so just like a Jay Cutler pass,
that gig
is totally up for grabs.
[ Laughter ]
Our resident Bears fan writer
stills has some beef
with Jay Cutler.
[ Laughter ]
Today was
national Massachusetts day.
Let me guess.
This calls for a drink?
[ Laughter ]
A fan rushed the field at
the Mets/Giants game last night
and stood
on the pitchers' mound.
Thankfully, he was only able to
strike out a few Mets
before he was apprehended.
[ Laughter ]
Sorry, everyone on the crew.
[ Laughs ]
Police officers in Germany
recently resuscitated
a Chihuahua using CPR.
Sadly, no one was willing
to give mouth-to-mouth
to the Saint Bernard.
And finally,
authorities in New York
arrested a man yesterday
after he allegedly set 14 fires
across Manhattan
within a few hours.
The man is facing up to
10 years in prison
and $1,200 in Uber fares.
And that was a monologue,
everybody.